The for loop is really useful to take words apart into the individual
characters. For example, when we have a word like this, we might want to look
at one character at a time. And what we're going to do in our sample program,
is count how many vowels this word has. Now, why does anyone care how many
vowels a word has? When you know how many vowels there are that gives you an
issue, an idea of how complicated the word is. And sometimes you actually have
to adjust your writing to be simpler. And then it's good to know that so just.
So, how do we do such a a thing. We need to, find, out, each of the characters.
And then, look at it more closely. Over here, you see how to look at the i'th
character. You take the substring, that goes from position i. Up to, but not
including position i plus 1. And that is a string containing a single
character. And we'll let I vary from 0 to the last valid index. That would be
the length minus 1. Notice that I starts at 0. It is less than the length that
makes means it goes up to the length minus 1 and it gets incremented by 1 every
time. This loop that you see here with this fore header and extracting the i-th
letter that's what you use every time that you want to break a word into its
individual characters. Now, onto our specific problem we want to count vowels.
The condition that you see here checks whether the letter is a vowel. it looks
a little backwards. We list all of the vowels, and we ask whether the letter
is any one of those. If we have a vowel. We increment a counter. The rest of
the program is simple. We print the result and also we need to declare a few
variables. Let's run the program. We're supposed to type in a word and we learn
that mouse has three vowels which doesn't surprise us. Actually is the bonus
fact of the day. Some words have more vowels than you think. Here's the French
word for bird, oiseau, and it has five vowels out of six letters. Which is hard
to imitate in English.